so as we look to the future of this
channel what I would like to start doing
is having discussions on Marvel films as
those films come out so the new Captain
America the Winter Soldier the new
amazing spider-man 2 Ant Man when that
film comes out I think maybe next year
but what I'd like to do is have
discussions about those I'd like to talk
about the characters talk about how I
view the characters and kind of how they
related to their comic book versions are
coming with counterparts some of the
things that I thought were great about
them some of the things that I thought
were negative about them and so what I
like to do is kind of do a dry run maybe
a test of some sort and that's what
we're going to do in this video in this
video we're going to be talking about
the Avengers
so before we get too far into this video
I do want to say that I thought the
Avengers was an enjoyable film so this
is not going to be a kind of knock
around smashdown kind of video on the
Avengers it was an enjoyable movie and I
walked out of the theater thinking that
was a fun movie to see and I would
definitely buy it on blu-ray you know I
thought it was a great movie but there
are a few things that I would have done
and this mentality is not something
that's isolated to the Avengers usually
whenever I see a film there's always a
few critiques that I have some things
that I would have done different and I
think that's kind of natural for most
everybody who goes to see a movie with
the Avengers in truth I kind of felt
like they rushed it I kind of felt like
that movie probably should not have come
out yet I think that the Avengers the
first Avengers film should probably be
the Avengers the New Avengers film is
coming out with Ultron being the main
villain and here's the reason why I felt
like a little more character development
could have been done around the
individual characters themselves there
were a lot of unanswered questions that
were going on for example what was Bruce
Banner doing between the time at the end
of the Incredible Hulk film when he's in
a hut and a jungle somewhere trying to
control his power and when we pick up
with him in Manila what was Thor doing
when he was in Asgard what was going on
with all these different things because
all the movies that have come out after
The Avengers were movies that have taken
place chronologically after the Avengers
and so for me there were some unanswered
questions questions that I would like to
have seen explained on the big screen in
addition the movie kind of felt like it
should have entitled Iron Man and the
Avengers when you go back and you watch
the film it really seems like Iron Man
gets more screen time than anybody else
in the film and to me it's a little
annoying
you know Iron Man is is a hilarious
character it needs portrayed
fantastically by Robert Downey jr. it's
really one of those roles where you
couldn't see anybody else except for
Robert Downey jr. playing the character
but the Avengers is an amalgamation of
superheroes fighting together against a
single foe it's not a superhero team
being led by one individual and that guy
uses everybody else's power to achieve a
goal or something like that and even if
that was the case the center of the show
the star of the movie
should have been Captain America but
when you look at films that have no real
center point no one character they can
focus on things really kind of tend to
go awry for example Star Wars Episode
one is really kind of the go-to source
for people who make a case about how you
have to have a main star in a film
because that film really had no main
story and it was an atrocity because of
it
but the difference here between the
Avengers and something like Star Wars
Episode one is that in Star Wars Episode
one the entire clan of Jedi was not the
center point of the movie it wasn't a
whole group of Jedi fighting a single
force it was supposed to be a sort of
revolving around Anakin's descent from
being a great person into the realm of
the darkside and becoming the focal
villain for episodes four five and six
with the Avengers what you had was a
team of superheroes who came together
due to external circumstances and
ultimately ended up kind of binding
together to form a cohesive team they
could fight off a force that no one else
could really stand against and I didn't
really feel like that's what happened in
this film I kind of felt like it was
people who came together by happenstance
and then they said oh god there's a
villain we gotta fight oh and with the
original Avengers ensemble what the way
the original team was put together it
was put together by the fact that there
were needed to be some kind of team to
fight against an external force that was
undefeatable by virtually every other
superhero team group at the time and
when I say at the time I mean you had
some very weak versions of popular
superhero team groups currently like the
x-men were very very weak compared to
the Avengers the Fantastic Four we're
very very weak compared to the Avengers
in addition to that I really felt like
ant-man Hank Pym should have been part
of the Avengers ensemble and I don't say
this for the sake of posterity I don't
say this because I'm a fan of ant-man or
because I'm kind of adhering to a past
ensemble of the team I say this simply
because hate him is a very important
character in the realm of Marvel Comics
due to his virtually unchallenged
intellect and the fact that he is the
creator of Ultron a machine that had
eventually rebelled and really kind of
took on the role of self-improvement and
challenging the Avengers and virtually
every turn I think that Ultron would
have made a great villain for the first
Avengers film because at this point
there's really one person that we can
look at and say that guy's the bad guy
and the Avengers film we didn't know if
the bad guy was burst banners alter-ego
the Incredible Hulk we even know if the
bad guy was the Chitauri and army
we didn't know if the bad guy was loki
you know and at the end of the day when
we finally see the post-credits scene we
realized the ultimate bad guy is Thanos
but it takes getting through two and a
half hours of a film and the credits to
finally see who the real bad guy is here
and in truth I think that you really
could have had a lot of interesting
dynamics in the Avengers film if you had
had Hank Pym in the film and he had been
the creator of Ultron because now you
can kind of dive into the realm of Hank
PEM's consciousness and his his guilt
over the creation of one of the most
powerful villains and Marvel Marvel
Comics and you could have easily kind of
delve into the question the had he known
that the result of his experimentations
would have been Ultron would he have
done it again and he probably would have
said no I wouldn't have done it all over
again you could kind of delve into the
realm of his guilt with regards to being
part of a team and having to destroy his
own creation different things like that
they really could have made for some
great stories some really great dialogue
and some great intertwining between the
characters and their ability to become
more of a cohesive unit than they were
before whoo that being said you know
again the film was not terrible it was
not bad if I were to make an Avengers
film in all honesty it would have been a
little slower it would have been a
build-up and there would have been two
films the first film would have been
kind of an ensemble of the characters
coming together the backstories of what
they were doing with regards to the time
that we saw them at the end of their
respective movies and the time that we
picked up with them in the Avengers film
it would have been a movie more on par
with No Country for Old Men and I know
that might write a for you it raised a
few eyebrows and some people might be
saying what but if you go back and you
watch the film No Country for Old Men is
all character development that's all it
is
I mean Anton Chigurh Josh Brolin's
character his name escapes me and Woody
Harrelson's character you know these
were all character developments Woody
Harrelson had
a probably total of 30 minutes of screen
time and yet by the time that he died
you realized that he was a pretty cool
guy he was he was pretty reasonable in
his own right in terms of being a bounty
hunter and so if you were to take this
concept of taking a first film and
making it in no country for all many
kind of film making it more drama making
a more focus on the characters and then
had the second film be more
action-packed the way the Avengers film
was to me I think that'd be pretty a
pretty successful recipe for a fantastic
film or a fantastic couple films but
again that's just me and my preference
on the kind of movies that I like to see
so with that being said I'm gonna go
ahead and bring this video to an end I
hope you guys enjoyed it if you did let
me know and I will catch you guys later
peace